let's talk about what's happening in new
york city we got this story from
timcast.com yeah new york proposes
ending religious exemptions inoculations
without parental consent and forced
removal of disease cases contacts and
carriers
changes to the state's public health
laws could mean more vaccine
requirements and new authority for the
governor here's what i love about this
story this uh this right up here at
timcast.com is all 100 percent factual
and correct but it also brings up a very
important uh assembly bill from new york
and that's bill a416
tim cass writes the new york legislature
will also consider assembly bill a416
which resembles the australian
quarantine camps that caught global
attention earlier this month assemblyman
and nick perry of brooklyn's 58th
district proposed the removal and
detention of anyone with a communicable
disease that warrants the new york
governor to declare a state of health
emergency due to an epidemic the funny
thing is a bunch of fact checkers
claimed that when this story emerged in
january it was fake news and they said
the reason was the bill is from 2015.
they're not planning so here's what they
do they say is there a law currently
about to be passed that would allow
covid patients to be indefinitely
detained false
there is a bill that would allow coveted
patients to be indefinitely detained but
it's for ebola
and it's never made it out of committee
anyway so it's fake news even though
it's true
there literally is a bill assembly bill
a416
since 2015 when it was introduced it's
gone to committee and then flopped it's
got no sponsors it doesn't go anywhere
but someone's certainly trying to make
it happen it would give the governor the
ability to just rendition you to take
you and put you wherever they deem fit
if they think you're a public health
threat
i'm not convinced it'll happen maybe it
is you know a little fear-mongery to be
bringing it up or whatever but if it's
there we ignore it and they do pass it
no one speaks about it then we'll regret
it yeah so what what can we do we have
to mention it exists and we got to tell
people in new york do not let them pass
this otherwise one day i'll get a knock
on the door from the nypd the the you
know the scumbags who are arresting
people for not having vax cards and then
they're gonna say come with me
oh my god yes i made the video and
that's not too far but what's been
happening in new york i mean we you see
the videos all over uh social media
people going in to panera bread saying
hey i just want to order some food
police officers coming in there acting
like they're big bad brave soldiers
meanwhile they were looking the other
way during blm riots they were twiddling
their thumbs not trying to get involved
with their eluding stories
if a man doesn't get government paper
permission to go to the panera bread oh
they're gonna go right on top of them
arrest them lock them up and rough them
up that's crazy so so i'll tell you you
know i point out that the police are
stomping on the middle class working
regular people that they're trying to
enforce that they're literally enforcing
government-mandated medical procedures
and i'll tell you what what makes me
feel like there is there's never going
to be that handshake moment left or
right between the the culture war
because i'm actually getting criticized
from the left for saying abolish the
police
they say yeah but tim's only saying it
because the police are stomping on
conservative civil rights and i'm like
well i'm talking about working-class
people but they're like doesn't matter
we we hate you and that's what it's all
about so if i see cops
walk in and arrest someone for
trespassing
why was he trespassing he'd never
vaccinate it's it's it's it's complete
bs sorry i'm not going to defend these
cops furthermore in that video of the of
the guy getting arrested a female cop is
stepping all over the american flag she
takes out of a guy's hand throws it on
the ground and then i don't think she
was stomping it on purpose some people
said she was wiping her feet on it no
she's just walking all over it she
doesn't care
this is the nypd so you know we had
we've had libby emmons tell us the nypd
wasn't enforcing this stuff well they
are now so if you live in new york
you this is this is this i don't know
man not everybody there voted for it
what does malice say there's no law too
absurd or evil that they won't enforce
there's no that would i'll try and
paraphrase there's no law so extreme and
egregious that the police would not
enforce it up and including executing
children absolutely history tells that
story and now we're seeing it slowly
being put into place with oh he didn't
have this paper he didn't get the
permission from the government to be
here take them away and they and they do
blindly so they have they have you know
a choice saying hey we're going to
respond to this call hey we're going to
take this seriously and for them to
punish people because they want to eat
food i mean what kind of levels of
insanity are we in that's crazy and it's
only going to get crazier from there
let's play get worse
how much do you want to bet i can make a
whole bunch of people
say the following sentence
yeah but it can't happen here
how much money can make them say that
uh pretty easy very very easily right
breakfast if i said
the police will absolutely kick your
door in and drag you from your home with
no crime committed and no due process if
ordered to by the mayor of new york
yep
if i said
police
regardless of where they are would go
into your house and they would drag you
out without due process people would say
yeah but it can't happen here now i'm
not saying everybody would a lot of
people are probably going like yep
absolutely and they will
because i'll tell you this especially if
you're from chicago i'm pretty sure
everyone in chicago just went yep
because i'll tell you i'll tell you what
happens in chicago in chicago i'm
hanging out with my friends cops kicked
our door with their guns drawn and just
walk into our house that's normal
completely normal in chicago they'll
drag you off to what they call the the
black site i think ian looked this up it
was in humboldt park maybe i'm not sure
yeah they just they just take you
without due process they kick your door
and they drag you from your home and
they bring you to an unmarked location
where they effectively you know torture
and detain you happens all the time what
yeah man yeah they had they had that guy
in chicago who was electrocuting people
with a cattle prod to force them into
confessing to crimes they didn't commit
wow wow so here's what happens you look
in new york city
and you've got a lot of people saying
like you know we've had libby emma's on
the show several times and she
repeatedly defends the nypd i won't do
that uh and we the first time she was
here we had an argument about the police
because i've been like not happy with
cops for a long time and i'm like dude
27 nypd officers
walked out you've got you've got mayor
bill de blasio who committed what i
would only describe as several felonies
misappropriating taxpayer funding to
paint a political message in front of
trump tower and then he went to the nypd
and says
you're going to protect this for me and
they went okay
so this dude literally commits some of
the highest level corruption and the
cops with a smile on their face said i
will arrest anyone who opposes you
like dude we're already there you can
defend the cops all day and night i
ain't going to do it because they're
literally they're they're they're you've
got the mayor of new york city
going on tv and saying we are going to
strip life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness from the citizens to force
them to undergo a medical procedure
and the nypd with a smile on their face
will arrest you if you try to buy food
but you're trespassing sorry it's for
your safety that's happening so we're
there so i don't thought you at all tim
i think that's a very good um you know
prediction but my thing is like
how do we even come back because okay
it's either comply
or goodbye like i said earlier right and
entertain would say
resist the slave mine because the thing
is is that like we're being brainwashed
to say you know what okay let's follow
the rules because this okay can we say
keep me you know my family together all
the stuff my thing is okay if we're
aware of what's happening how do we
contract because you know we're aware of
what's happening but walk we understand
you know what's really happening behind
the scenes how do you combat this
uh cops should quit if there's police
officers who are aware of what's going
on they should quit many have we've
covered those stories over and over and
over again because a lot of a lot of
cops are just like i am done with this
call it out when it happens and stop
worshiping authority one of my favorite
memes is this kind of like maga hat
trump supporter small shriveled up guy
going up to a cop who's the kind of chad
here and he's like i love you you're
great i support i back to blue and the
chad being like off to the gulag you
january sixth insurrectionist and then
that's literally what's happening here
we're seeing the politicization of the
justice system in such a bastardized way
it's crazy to see it happen right in
front of our face and the only way to
stop it not comply peacefully
don't go along with it call it out when
it happens and don't incentivize it i
mean if you live in new york city your
taxes are supporting that system you're
voting incentivizing those people to do
those things remember when those
detectives tried to imprison cal
rittenhouse for the rest of his life yep
you know back the blue baby
remember when a political message was
painted on streets across the country
and we all said just like in that quote
from 1984 about how streets will be
renamed and the police came out and
arrested anybody who tried to protest it
back the blue baby remember when cops
showed up to a woman in new jersey's
store because she was live streaming on
facebook things she had for sale and
they said you're not allowed to run your
business got to back the blue right
man i could go on and on and on couldn't
i yes celebrations like that are just
terrible man because now you're
infringing on people's ability to make
money to live you know and and it's
crazy because
i mean i'm originally from connecticut
so i definitely are familiar with the
city and how new york city politics are
and here's the other thing too people
are kind of realizing waking up because
i'll tell you this florida real estate
has been exploding like i can't even get
a property right now because all the new
yorkers are moving down well
no no that that's that's not true that's
that's absolutely that can't be possible
you're lying because the new yorkers
believe that miami is sinking
don't they all believe that the the
water is going to rise 20 feet and floor
is going to get wet i think i i guess
they're so bad about wearing a mask
they're like screw this i'm going to
florida i don't care
my friend we are being overrun by new
yorkers i can't tell you how many crazy
even in dating apps a bunch of new york
girls real estate real estate rent
prices have went up 38 yeah in the city
of miami alone in the past year property
values yeah
i was looking i was looking at
properties where i used to live because
i was in the redlands and that's insane
i'm like that little tiny thing is going
for a million bucks you're crazy i went
there last year looking for property i
couldn't find anything it's worse now
new york california new jersey a lot of
people moving from connecticut as well
the northeast in general like outside of
new hampshire they're all coming down to
florida and from california as well the
people people from l.a and southern
california they're either going to vegas
or they're coming to florida or they're
going to texas i got it i got a house in
jersey and uh and we were like thinking
of selling it because we're not we're
not there anymore and they're just like
when we got told the general like area
property value i was like
well i lost all my money
nobody wants to live it actually went
down yeah because because in general new
jersey
i bought a property right
last year
333 333k about property for a year later
500k it's like values are going way up
man
without giving away too much private
information they they they told us a
very low number where it it's gone up
since we bought it but we bought it
before the pandemic so at this point i'm
like how is that what it's like what
they're what they're saying that the
area is worth so i don't know if we'll
be able to actually sell anything get
rid of it and go to florida man yeah man
go to florida 10 30 exchange 10 30 30.
i'll tell you i'm gonna be going down
there you got you got you know dave
rubin posted this compilation of all
these floridians being like welcome to
florida dave welcome to florida it's
like oh yeah well west virginia is where
it's it man we're building a big
facility we're building like 7 500
square feet 25 foot you know walls it's
gonna be massive inside we're building a
new studio building we're going to have
a whole bunch of stuff going on west
virginia freedom standing well a lot i
know a lot of real estate investors
actually invest in west virginia
fantastic place to invest right now bro
there was a hundred th there's you can
get like a history for a hundred grand
exactly one idea as well when i said the
first time i had a bunch of people be
like a hundred grand is not cheap and
i'm like a hundred acres for a hundred
grand is cheap tell that sell that new
jersey property take it over to west
virginia man you're gonna use a bunch of
money and tax free man you get a you go
you go to like the the new york metro or
north jersey and it's like
point two of an acre is a million bucks
like like if you're lucky you'll get
like point zero one of an acre it's like
a townhouse sandwich between two
buildings and it's 500 grand i've never
understood why people enjoy living i
mean no offense i have a family that
live in new york city but i've never
liked it i i've always thought it was
dirty expensive dangerous like why you
know what i'm saying and then you've got
this craziness going on with this clown
world where they're arresting you for
trying to go to panera bread without a
mask and it's like come on man and the
thing is this i obviously used to work
in law enforcement and most people i get
on the job
honestly want to get on there to help
people yeah obviously you got your bad
apples and everything else like that but
a lot of guys come on trying to you know
do right and everything else and i'll
tell you man a lot of guys resigning
from the force because of having to
enforce stupid laws like this
it's sad man it's sad no one wants to
get on the job to rescue foreign's last
podcast
right now what are you guys investing in
for investments
cryptocurrency crypto bam retail uh um
real estate yeah
yeah are you the government i ain't
telling you
we're the best
uh
with me
myself the business bam exactly exactly
business real estate crypto yeah we're
putting we're putting a lot into
building the new facility because uh
this place is great and we're still
gonna have it we're gonna use it for a
lot of production stuff we already
record like several shows this place is
lit man this is this dope man as a
production guy like i love wait till you
see senior equipment we fought we signed
off on the new building so we're going
to have 50 acres
we're going to have our own shooting
range we're going to have dirt jumps
we're going to have a skate park and
we're going to be able to film tons of
stuff we're going to have a green screen
room
so basically we can film and put someone
anywhere you know what it means like we
could we could make sci-fi movies or
west virginia has better gun laws right
lack thereof yeah yeah nice yeah new
hampshire constitutional campaign i'm
sure yeah new hampshire is the best
place to be in new england i love new
hampshire yep
if you if you walk around in west
virginia carrying like a you know a
barrett m82 or whatever the worst thing
that's gonna happen is
someone's gonna walk up to you and and
say be like are you crazy for carrying
that thing it must be so heavy cool gun
though
big fan and that's what i used to live
in texas man you know gun-friendly state
you know and
yeah i mean
i was surprised they only just passed
constitutional carry in texas though yep
for a long time you it was kind of hard
harder
to do that you mean like you mean like
open carry no no no so it up until last
year if you wanted a handgun in texas
you'd take a class then get like a
license or something like a handgun
permit oh yeah yeah if you want to carry
it out but if you want to have it in
your house no no no no just to buy
constitutional carry is new in texas you
can walk and buy it walk around with it
in your hand just don't point it at
people you know what i mean
now that constitutional carry is new in
texas you used to need permits and stuff
yup wow
yeah well i bought it you know obviously
for the job so yeah i i didn't know that
but i know obviously you could invest in
firearms and bullets dude that's
something i do but we did we did an
interview with robert kiyosaki we talked
about that you know uh i think silver i
i invested silver as well i've got
something to get some gold um but yeah
ammunition ammo is gonna be i remember
you mentioned that last week we talked
about this i got an edge i got an n all
right you guys want to know what you
need to get yeah bottle caps
why
because because in fallout oh yeah yeah
universe everyone uses bottle caps as
currency of course so that's what you
need you need bottle caps
i'm kidding it's a video game
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you